[Música]
quiero darles una charla una emisión
poco alternativa y hablarles sobre un
proyecto en el cual estamos trabajando
le va a dar energía a la tierra por
muchos muchos años
la ilusión que tenemos es tratar de
producir un sol en la tierra y porque
queremos reproducir un sol en la tierra
es únicamente porque la energía es el
gran motor que mueve al mundo pueden
pensar varias razones por la cual esto
es importante número uno es el corazón
del desarrollo olvidemos por un momento
las luces el celular
netflix el facebook todas herramientas
superficiales que usamos de vez en
cuando sin energía no tendríamos
absolutamente nada de los elementos
básicos que necesita el ser humano para
su subsistencia y por ende para su
desarrollo número 2 sin energía las
comunidades viven en total la oscuridad
como pueden ver en este mapa acordémonos
que pasó en venezuela hace unos pocos
años cuando entraron en apagones por más
de una semana
los apagones quitaron la electricidad y
el agua y puso en jaque el transporte de
educación actividades laborales sumieron
alimentos y la vida
miles de personas ancianos y niños
también
número 3 el acceso a energía es esencial
para reducir pobreza y eso también
debería ser adoptado en nuestros países
pero sigamos hablando del mundo 1 de
cada 7 personas en todo el planeta vive
sin electricidad y 3 de cada 7 personas
del mundo entero siguen usando
combustibles contaminantes que afectan
su salud socavan su perspectiva de vida
y su desarrollo y número 4 la energía
también hace posible las innovaciones y
las nuevas industrias y estas últimas
son los únicos motores de generación de
empleo y crecimiento de un país de todo
el mundo y en especial del nuestro pero
porque llego al texto a contarles esto a
dejar la impresión de que necesitamos
energía es porque la necesitamos aquí en
el historial del tiempo los últimos dos
ciclos pueden ver en la generación y el
consumo de energía en todo el mundo
actualmente es a ese uso es
prácticamente una carrera exponencial
que tiene dos motivos
1 la cantidad de gente que hay en el
mundo se multiplica día a día y número 2
la cantidad de energía que usa un humano
promedio como nosotros también se
multiplica
sin importar qué tipo de energía usemos
ellas está creada por alcoholes o por
carbón o por aceite o por gas natural
más del 80% de la energía del mundo es
poco amigable y como poco amigable me
refiero a que producen mucho co2 cuanto
aquí ven un mapa solo miren la data
sobre las miles de toneladas de co2 que
se vierten al ambiente y quieren ser
responsables obviamente los países
grandes pero en esta economía global la
cual todos vivimos todos todos somos
responsables y en primera aproximación
que es lo que podemos hacer bueno
deberíamos cambiar un poco como
obtenemos energía y como usamos energía
número uno y quizás la única solución es
cómo descarbonizar nuestras economías es
la única solución que tenemos que hacer
la palabra descarbonizar no significa
dejar de usarlas así de pronto significa
entrar a un estado de equilibrio y poco
a poco dejar de usarlas en la curva de
arriba de la izquierda a la roja en esa
curva exponencial de uso de energía y
producción de co2 en la cual trae como
consecuencia un aumento de la
temperatura de los océanos y la tierra
en general
hoy en día alrededor del 2020 estamos en
un año bastante bastante crítico porque
porque ya deberíamos estabilizar esa
curva y en vez de unos hacia arriba en
la curva roja de arriba o de abajo
deberíamos empezar a estabilizarnos e ir
hacia abajo para descarbonizar nuestra
economía pero es muy fácil decirlo hay
dos recetas que les quiero traer hoy en
día la número uno que quizás la que más
deben conocer es la solución de las
renovables
la solución solar y la solución eólica
que pueden darle energía a todo un país
a una ciudad y hoy en día hay industrias
modernas
lamentablemente es una solución de baja
densidad qué significa eso significa que
utilizamos un terreno bastante bastante
amplio como en el desierto de mojave en
california para poner todo un conjunto
de paneles solares o soluciones eólicas
para tener energía una gran cantidad de
energía eso es de baja densidad número 2
no existe en todos lados como ve en el
mapa de la izquierda pueden ver que ese
potencial fotovoltaico existe mucho en
la parte de la izquierda de la parte
norte américa norte y este oeste de los
eeuu por ejemplo que pasa en la parte
este bueno en la parte este no existe
ese potencial entonces debe hacerse algo
diferente y número tres resoluciones
eólicas y fotovoltaicas tienen el
problema de tiempo que no hay luz todo
el día o no hay viento todo el día y la
forma como consumimos energía es energía
constante
hay otra solución la 'número dos' una
solución de alta densidad y aquí está la
palabra grande que vengo a traerles la
solución nuclear es la solución que
asusta a mucha gente y les pongo de
nuevo el mapa a los eeuu como ejemplo la
solución nuclear se aplica mucho en el
lado derecho y no el lado izquierdo
donde les enseñe la solución
fotovoltaica por ejemplo porque porque
en lado derecho no hay terrenos grandes
como el desierto de california para
poner esos paneles solares hay alrededor
de 100 reactores nucleares en ese lado
derecho de este mapa pero lo que quiero
decirles en lo que yo quiero es
convencer es cuál es la forma como que
se debe aprovechar ese potencial nuclear
también es súper súper fácil decirlo
haces 100 y tantos años una persona que
trajo con elegancia impresionante un
concepto bastante complicado una
elegancia que involucraba mucha física y
mucha matemática y nos dio soluciones a
como seis cosas importantes que los
humanos no entendíamos muy bien una de
ellas es la solución nuclear esa persona
se llamaba albert einstein
albert eisntein trato de explicar algo
con elegancia tremenda que representaba
para todos nosotros algo súper súper
complicado cómo es eso que la masa no se
crea ni se destruye sólo se transforma
eso que para algunos es imposible
entender einstein lo explico y lo llevó
algo muy muy simple imagínense ustedes
que comienza una reacción nuclear de
ahora en adelante les voy a hablar de
tres o cuatro ejemplos para aterrizar
cómo se hace esto y vamos a hacer
matemáticas todos juntos
comenzamos con una reacción nuclear de
inicio 5 partículas al lado izquierdo la
reacción nuclear ocurre y acabó con 5
partículas ordenadas de una forma
diferente hacia el lado derecho crean o
no en las reacciones nucleares o en las
desintegraciones nucleares la masa final
siempre es menor
bueno qué pasó con el principio la masa
no se crea ni se destruye sólo se
transforma y se transforma en que en
energía de ahí sale la famosa ecuación
de einstein e igual a ms cuadrado y aquí
van las matemáticas listos número uno
qué diablos s
se es la velocidad de la luz ya les
pongo hay una cantidad
aterricemos ustedes se van a la playa en
su carro 100 kilómetros por hora la
velocidad de la luz es 100 millones de
veces más rápido que la velocidad que
tienen ustedes tienen 8 ceros al costado
de la velocidad que lleva ustedes en un
auto 8 y si les vamos al cuadrado
duplicamos la cantidad de ser tendremos
16 ceros si esas masas que se pierden la
reacción nuclear es pequeñísima no
interesa estamos multiplicando por 16
ceros en una ecuación el producto sigue
siendo enorme
número 2
yo mido 184 peso casi 100 kilos entre
muertos y heridos
imaginemos que mi masa de pronto vamos a
convertirla en solamente energía
y si llevan bien las unidades en una
multiplicación en física se van a dar
cuenta que la energía que podemos
producir con mi masa
es tanta energía como darle energía al
perú o 70 80 años a todo el perú ok es
realmente impresionante entonces hay dos
cosas nucleares que ahora que tienen que
saber porque ustedes van a tener la casi
no expertos en física nuclear
número 1 fisión nuclear la fisión
nuclear la ficción es separar romper es
usar un martillo grande llamado neutrón
que parte una partícula enorme como el
uranio y el plutonio el torio esas cosas
feas no quiere usar nunca en su vida y
termina una reacción nuclear y obtiene
energía la ecuación de einstein hay
muchos países los eeuu países en europa
que dicen enlace tipo japón que usan
fisión nuclear y les va muy bien
desgraciadamente asociamos la fisión
nuclear a los desastres la bomba de
hiroshima y nagasaki el desastre de
chernóbil y el desastre de fukushima por
el tsunami entonces esto quizás no es
muy bien aceptado por la cante por la
mayoría de la gente eso es ficción ese
es partir bueno ahora él es algo
diferente fusión fusión quiero unir y
así como la afición es elementos pesados
la fusión fusión a une elementos súper
livianos elementos supervivientes del
agua
de los constituyentes del hidrógeno unos
parientes del hidrógeno que se llaman
deuterio y tritio y entre nosotros se
llaman isótopos ok pero es solamente
proviene del agua y a la hora que
isótopos se fusionan hacemos una
reacción de fusión nuclear y obtenemos
helio para los globos y obtenemos un
neutrón que va a calentar agua y nos va
la electricidad ok y ahora viene el
cuarto juicio matemático
imaginemos que estamos en la ciudad de
lima en la ciudad de lima consume algo
así como que un gigavatio de potencia
eléctrica por todo un año
y el ejercicio es este de acá
cuántos vagones de carbón cree usted que
se necesitaría para iluminar a toda la
ciudad
este tema será un cálculo 23 un poquito
más esto es una especie de parrilla de
fin de semana es un poquito más
complicado
20 200
30.000 vagones de carbón tienen que
quemarse para darle potencia eléctrica a
una ciudad como lima bueno ahora hago mi
magia de la nuclear
cuánta agua necesitaría yo para hacer
fusión nuclear y darle energía a todo
lima solamente una camioneta nada más
ok entonces la pregunta que debe tener
ustedes es bueno que estamos esperando
la fusión nuclear es una alternativa
alucinante es ideal para resolver este
paradigma este desafío de energía
mundial el problema es que es súper
complicado cree varios beneficios número
uno es limpia no tiene desechos
radioactivos no tiene dióxido de carbono
no tiene smoke es segura no hay
posibilidad que haya reacción en cadena
y no tiene amenaza de purificación
nuclear número 3 es prácticamente
inagotable en este mundo y agua para
miles de miles de millones de años ese
no es el problema en el futuro va a
estar disponible las 24 horas del día y
es totalmente independiente a educación
geográfica podría hacerse en el perú
puede ser en china podría decir la mitad
del mar también
pero cuáles son los problemas porque
vivir felipe no puede hacer esto porque
porque tratamos de hacer justamente lo
que sucede en el sol el sol y las
estrellas nos enseñan cómo hacer fusión
nuclear y para hacer eso necesitamos
conocer el universo necesitamos conocer
astrofísica mecánica gravitación
magnetismo electricidad cuántica
termodinámica estás energías ya física
nuclear y fusión ya se la saben
obviamente pero hay una que nos falta
una súper básica en nuestro campo y es
física de plasmas en el sol la materia
no está como acá como el sólido como el
líquido como el gaseoso en sus casas o
aquí mismo lo que respiramos en el sol
la materia está en otro estado
totalmente distinto que se llama plasma
el estado de la materia tiene
temperaturas muy muy altas en el sol
entre 1 y 10 millones de grados la
temperatura que necesitamos aquí en la
tierra es alrededor de 300 millones de
grados
créanlo o no en el sol todo ya está
juntito aquí en la tierra hay que
juntarlos todo entonces tenemos que
entender cómo es la materia a esa
temperatura no es líquido no es sólido
no es gracioso es un plasma como es el
cambio el cambio ocurre por temperatura
comienzo con un pedazo de hielo lo
caliento obtengo un gas perdón un
líquido
caliento el líquido como nuestra cocina
y que obtengo un gas y ahora quiero
pasar a otro estado a la materia
a un plasma y debo de aumentar
temperatura la secuencia es simplemente
por un aumento de temperatura como
caliento el gas es una forma bien rara
que voy a tratar de explicarse las el
hidrógeno tiene un átomo positivo de
auto mone gatti bo el ese electrón va
girando alrededor de este protón a la
hora que uno aumenta la energía este
electrón sale de la órbita y por él no
tengo una sopa de partículas cargadas
positivas a un lado negativas a otro y
se le voy a tratar de demostrar en este
tubo como lo que tienen en sus baños o
aquí mismo en este auditorio tiene un
tubo fluorescente donde hay un gas un
gas en el estado
obviamente gaseoso pero quiero hacerles
un plasma y voy a poner
algo de energía
y al poner energía cerca a un gas y
ustedes lo hacen piénselo todos los días
cada experimento florescentes de pronto
hay una luz
ese estado de la materia dentro que yo
puedo apagar y puedo aprender es el
estado de plateau y créanlo no ya está a
miles de grados centígrados yo puedo ser
un plasma aquí o puedo ser un plasma
también en el aire
ok esto ya está crean o no esas
partículas que viajan de este electrodo
a este de acá ya están alrededor de
10.000 grados centígrados
bueno como hacemos
para que estas cargas eléctricas
nos ayuden y hacer fusión nuclear bueno
las ponemos dentro de una botella
magnética que se llama tokamak por una
palabra en ruso es un arreglo de bobinas
magnéticas así como las que hay las
licuadoras o los motores que mueven las
cargas eléctricas hacen flotar este
plasma por ese plasma se ha calentado y
noto que las paredes de los bordes
porque obviamente algo a un millón de
grados oa 300 millones de grados va a
derretir la máquina entonces se crea
esta máquina en esta máquina hay en
varios países del mundo y competimos
todos los días
pesas adiós ahora queremos las cosas
juntos hace poco se ha creado un
proyecto que se llama iter que junta a
más o menos como 5000 técnicos
ingenieros y científicos para hacer
viable este proyecto iter que en latín
significa la vía sigue importar nuestra
nacionalidad nuestra raza nuestra género
orientación solamente importa crear la
energía para el futuro este es hiper un
proyecto de 35 billones de dólares que
se construye en el sur de francia con la
el ghoul de darle energía al mundo
entonces el mensaje es estudié en
ciencia por favor hagan ciencia no es
difícil es súper fácil es fascinante es
una carrera alucinante necesitamos
técnicos ingenieros químicos físicos
hombres y mujeres de cualquier rincón
del mundo inclusive de nuestro perú
y esta es la carrera ayúdennos a crear
un solo delante muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]